All right guys.
Uh,
first off,
sorry about the delay there.
I'm just gonna start slowly here today because we had another link that we
normally set up through the tri caster through our studio cameras and the whole
freaking thing.
And then the tri caster.
Some of you know about the tribe cast here.
We try guesser is like one of the few ways that you can sort of build out a
studio and control all the cameras and all that.
It is a notoriously herky jerky thing that often has crazy bugs and a mirror
here.
Our director who was an absolute pro and all this and has been doing this for
years,
she did every possible thing imaginable,
uh,
so that we could be doing this normally as we normally do it through our regular
cameras and all that good stuff.
And I'm miked up and it's lit well and everything.
But for some reason the tri caster just didn't want to play along.
I don't know what the hell is going on.
So we're doing this old school people.
I've got my laptop right in front of me and,
uh,
we're just,
we're going to do it this way.
Uh,
there's a whole bunch of stuff that I want to catch up with you guys on.
You know,
I've been on this tour with JP Jordan Peterson and because of that,
for the last whatever it is,
almost six,
eight weeks,
I haven't been doing direct messages at the front end of the shows.
And that's usually when I'm able to tell you guys what I've been thinking about,
what's on my mind,
what I think is relevant and important and all that stuff.
But we just haven't been able to do that because although we've taped some shows
in advance,
um,
usually when I'm doing something that's on my mind at the moment,
there's a bit of a topical nature to it.
So I don't want to tape a DM even a week in advance and then lay it out when it
feels stale or old.
So I haven't had a moment,
uh,
in the last couple of weeks to just go directly to you guys.
What I have had is a couple of chances to do that with,
uh,
with those of you who are on Patrion because I do the one on ones and the group
hangouts and all that kind of stuff.
Um,
so I've been able to share some thoughts about this tour and just all the kinds
of stuff that's going on.
Um,
and then I want to share some,
some personal stuff,
some business stuff.
We're going to do a,
an Ama,
you guys can ask me anything.
You can do that on super chat right here.
So for those of you that don't have super chat works,
uh,
if you throw in a couple of bucks in the youtube comment section that pumps your
comments up,
I'm pretty sure that the more you put,
the longer it stays up there,
then my guys can see it and they send it to me.
We've got a trusty iPad here with,
uh,
with Patrion questions rolling in and with,
with super chat comments rolling in and all that good stuff.
Um,
we are streaming right now,
we're only streaming on youtube.
Sometimes we stream this on,
uh,
on Facebook as well.
But because of this whacked out of tricaster situation,
uh,
we're just doing it this way.
Uh,
yes,
I am wearing the classical liberal tee shirt.
Uh,
many of you guys saw no,
this is a good place to start actually.
So last week we posted a,
I believe it was,
uh,
was it last Tuesday,
if I'm not mistaken,
a week ago today we posted our first ever Ruben report animated video.
Uh,
it was a two minute 37 second videos or short that I wrote and did the voiceover
for,
we've got a great animator who came in and we did what is classical liberalism.
It got something like last I saw,
I think it around 650,000 views on Twitter.
I think it's got about a hundred thousand on youtube,
which is kind of an interesting little thing about the algorithms and whatever
else is going on here with the feeds or however you guys ingest this content.
There's something interesting happening.
So think about this.
I have about,
uh,
last I saw,
I think it's around 400,
some odd thousand Twitter followers.
The video on Twitter got about 700,000 views.
We have almost 800,000 subscribers on youtube.
So basically double the subscribers that I have on Twitter.
The video got,
at last I saw it was a little bit under a hundred thousand views.
Now you got to keep bumping into you guys on the street or when I go to the
Petersen events are you guys email me and you keep telling me I'm subscribed,
but I don't see the videos.
I don't know what's going on with the feed.
I get the usual nonsense from youtube who'd,
I don't know what the answer to any of it is anymore.
I'm just going to keep putting out stuff and hopefully for those of you that
don't see the videos in your feeds or whatever they are,
hopefully you do a little extra legwork to find the stuff.
Um,
but we're doing,
we're doing the best we can.
We're also working on a couple of things that I can't quite get into yet on that
front.
How was that for your teas?
We're just working on some stuff on that front.
Um,
anyway,
we put this video out and what I wanted to do with this was because obviously in
the last two years,
and I think it has a little something to do with what we've been doing around
here,
the ideas of classical liberalism have been catching on.
And something sort of beautiful happened today that I'm sure many of you saw
Barack Obama,
former president Barack Obama,
was given a speech today.
And he talked about how you cannot automatically dismiss people's opinions just
because they're male or just because they're white.
I mean,
I suspect that the conversations that we've all been having here between
Peterson and Rogan and the line steins and Sam Harrison,
Shapiro and everybody else,
but these conversations we know,
I mean I can't get into every little detail of how we know everything we know,
but we know that these conversations have moved up the ladder and then a lot of
people all over the world,
uh,
important,
powerful people are taking note of this and taking note of the massive amounts
of numbers of people that are listening to these podcasts and being influenced
by this stuff.
And the fact that Peterson has sold about 2 million books,
it may be more than 2 million already about a month ago it was one and a half
million.
I mean this thing is,
it's actually incredible.
When I was in DC a couple of weeks ago for the Peterson event and then I did a,
I did a sold out show and back doing stand up and I did a sold out show at the
DC and profit.
It was awesome.
Thank you for all of you guys that came there and we did a meet and greet after,
which was totally fun.
It was great.
I brought up Christina Hoff summers for the second half of the show is great.
But anyway,
I was in DC and I went to this little party and I don't,
I can't say who was there because I don't know if he wants to be known as
somebody,
but there was a senator there who was a very influential senator,
one of the most influential senators and all of the Senate,
and he was there and I walked in and he's like,
Hey Dave Rubin,
I know you're on tour where Peterson,
I'm reading this book right now.
So cool things are happening.
This stuff is starting percolate and I don't think it's a coincidence that
Barack Obama came out and did a real,
that was a real swipe of identity politics.
And you know,
it's interesting because there's so many things happening here at once and we
were watching the massive realignment of politics and media.
It's all happening together.
This is the fertile ground we've been talking about for the last couple of years
here.
We're watching it sort of all shake out right now and we don't know what it'll
be on the other side,
but it's exciting.
I think if you're aware,
uh,
and you're,
you've got a couple of neurons still firing and you're paying attention to
what's going on.
So when Barack Obama does that,
that's a signal I think to some of the same lefties.
And by the way,
there are sane lefties,
right?
I used to know a lot of them.
Um,
and we need,
I think a same left and a sane.
Right.
And I would love to see for all of my frustrations with the left that you guys
know,
I talk about all the times and I hate identity politics and I hate with the
Democratic Party has become and they oppression Olympics and all of this
nonsense.
And I think there are way to big government and all of that for all of that.
If the same part of the left came back,
the part of the left that for those of you that are libertarian or conservative
or whatever that you may disagree with,
but I think you believe our principal or should at least believe their
principal.
So if the part of the left that say Bret Weinstein,
who considered until deeply progressive for his whole life believed in or his
wife had their hiring,
uh,
believed in,
if that same part of the left or the part of the left that I once was part of
when I considered myself a Democrat and when Democrats were actually liberal,
not leftist,
were when they were open minded,
not totalitarian,
if that came back,
that would be good for everything.
So there's something interesting going on right now because I see right now I
see three sort of distinct pieces or a,
we can say I see three distinct,
um,
units on the right.
So right now you've got the Trump people,
the mag of people.
Okay.
Big Column right there.
That's a,
that's an ideological column.
Then you have been never Trumpers,
the sort of more old school conservative Bam.
Okay.
These are very separate people,
but they're throwing them on the right or they're thought of as Republican or
Conservative,
whatever you want to call that.
Then there's also what I what the part that I liked the most,
which is I think there is a very strong growing libertarian wing of the
Conservative Party.
When I go to these Peters that events,
when I speak at colleges,
when I do stand up,
I talk about libertarian ideas and that's when people get most excited.
So there's three distinct ideologies right now within the right,
so to speak,
right?
So we've got the Trump people,
the never Trump people,
old school conservative,
and we've got libertarians.
They're all fighting for control of their thing,
of their party,
of their ideology,
all that.
That's great.
That's a beautiful thing.
You know,
it's unfortunate when when you just see them fighting at each other to the point
where they hate each other and these people are evil and those people we will,
that gets nobody anywhere.
What a beautiful thing.
If you have an ideological war or the right way,
like really fighting out ideas.
That's a beautiful thing.
And I think that's what we tried to do around here right now on the left.
Unfortunately,
um,
we don't see as much of that because there has been a purging of the liberals
and the progressives and the democratic socialists and that crew that wants
really big government and that does judge on your skin color and your immutable
characteristics and thinks that government can solve all the problems.
They have basically purged out all of the scene.
San Jose saying all the,
um,
more,
uh,
pleasant,
thoughtful liberals,
let's say.
And I do see,
and that's why I said this would be the year of unusual alliances.
I see a lot of old school liberals finding a lot more in common,
in common with old school.
Conservatives are certainly the libertarian people.
And I guess some of them are magnet people too,
but there isn't an ideological fight there really because it's basically just
been a slaughter where there's almost nobody left.
So that's why today I thought it was so interesting because by Obama saying in
effect he said identity politics are are bullshit.
And you have to be able to listen to people,
even scary white men.
Yeah.
You have to be able to listen to them because they might have good ideas.
Uh,
that's pretty powerful.
And if that signals some sort of comeback on the left of that theory,
um,
and that takes root a little bit.
I think that would be great.
And you know,
Peterson in a lot of the events that we talk about,
because one of the things that happens is we do a Q and a at the end.
And what happens is we use an APP called Slido.
So when,
when we first started,
we were just letting people come up to the mic to do the Q and a.
But what happens is people are so excited,
they ended up telling their life story and they very long winded things and
sometimes they're very nervous and they lose their train of thought and a whole
bunch of stuff.
And we want to get to as many questions as possible.
So what we do now is there's an app called Slido,
Sli Dot Deo and people that are in the audience and they're usually three to
four to 5,000 people at the audience and these shows.
And it's just been incredible.
I'll tell you a little bit more about that later.
Uh,
people submit questions on the APP and then while Peterson is doing his thing,
so basically the way the show works is I go up there for about 10 or 15 minutes.
I do warm up,
I welcome everybody.
We do some silly stuff.
I talked about lobsters and cleaning your room and I just get everybody going
and everybody's in a great mood and people are screaming and it's,
and it's just wonderful.
It's none of the things that these awful,
uh,
articles and slime ball,
you know,
hack pieces are saying about him or about what's going on there.
So,
anyway,
so I do my thing that I bring out.
Peter's in Jordan talks about everything,
everything under the sun for an hour and a half.
Sometimes he talks about 12 rules.
Sometimes he talks about the media,
sometimes he talks about the intellectual dark web.
So 19 talks about what's whatever else is on his mind.
Every single one of these shows has been different.
It's been,
it's been truly incredible being on this tour.
I mean the guy is a,
is a true tour de force and whether you love him or hate him or you're
indifferent or whatever,
it's like,
it's just so cool being around it.
I,
I've just thoroughly enjoyed every,
every second of it and I've enjoyed also just bouncing around from city to city
and figuring out which cities I like Warren and just the differences of the
people.
I got to say,
if any of you guys were at the Nashville show,
you are the happiest freaking bunch of people I've ever seen in my entire life.
I don't know what is in the water in Nashville,
but uh,
that,
that's the one that really stuck out to me.
And we were in the Ryman theater,
which is from the grand old Opry and just the history there.
But we've been in amazing theaters and it's so cool because we go to these
really old school theaters that are kind of like phantom of the opera.
Then we've been to some,
some newer,
more and more,
uh,
modern theaters and just,
and the people are great.
And anyway,
in any event,
uh,
people submit questions during the show and then while Jordan's doing his thing,
I basically look through them and Jordan made it very clear to me from the
beginning.
He said,
nothing is off limits.
I want you to challenge me,
etcetera,
etcetera.
So I go through,
I find some silly ones.
I find some funny ones.
I find some,
some,
some painful ones.
I find some hard ones,
some political ones.
I'm not political.
One's a personal ones,
psychological questions,
I mean all sorts of stuff.
And we do that at the end for about 30 to 45 minutes.
And it's just,
it's just been absolutely great.
And uh,
you know,
it's so funny because being on this tour with the guy,
it's like as we're on the tour,
hit pieces come out.
So like that ridiculous enforced monogamy article came out in the New York Times
and I had met the author of it the two or three days before she was sitting in
the green room with us at our first show in Toronto.
And it's like,
she seemed like a great gal.
I talked about this a little bit when I had uh,
Jordan in here with Eric clients then a couple of weeks ago and it's like,
and then just writes this piece that as if Jordan is trying to force anyone to
be married or force women into monogamy or anything enforcement ivy,
he meant marriage.
That's all he meant.
And it's like you watch these people in these slime bags and often I've invited
people to come to the show after they've written bad pieces.
Uh,
there has been a writer,
um,
uh,
a guy from the blaze who spent a couple of days with us who's writing a piece
right now,
who wrote a profile piece on me a couple months ago that I think is going to be
an excellent piece coming out about the tour because I took the time to learn,
to trust the guy who's worth as much as I can trust a reporter.
And we spent some time with him and all that.
Um,
but unfortunately,
you know what's happened these days because of the clickbait machine that you
guys know about,
that these guys real,
all of these reporters,
but they're activists,
they're not journalists.
And what they do is they go,
holy cow,
Peterson's got the number one book.
He's selling out these theaters now.
He's doing these things with Sam Harris where they're getting,
you know,
8,000,
9,000 people overseas.
And it's like,
well,
instead of learning what's actually going there.
So instead of actually showing up to the show and reporting on the truth that
has nothing to do with racism or massage,
he,
he's actually giving you the tools by,
by,
uh,
empowering your own life,
by cleaning your own room.
He's giving you the tools to not be racist,
to not be big enough to not to hate cultural Marxism and the progressive
politics of,
of,
uh,
the oppression Olympics of,
of all of that stuff he's telling you hate that,
but also,
well,
not hate it.
That's not even the right word.
No.
What it is and know why it's wrong.
And then he's also saying the identity politics of the right are just as bad.
He focuses more on the left as I focus more or less because that seems to be the
thing that's the cultural norm that is jammed down our throat every day.
But these reporters,
they don't even been show up to these things because they just want to write
something so that they can get more clicks.
They're just in the click business.
And,
uh,
and I don't think any of us,
you know,
this whole crew of people,
IDW,
whatever you want to call it,
I don't think we're in the club business.
There'd be a lot of ways for us to get more clicks.
I mean,
you can look at the way we tag and title all of our videos.
We know if we use certain buzz words are capitalized,
certain things differently or Gotcha destroys blah,
blah,
blah.
It's like we know we can get more clicks,
but it's really not about that we're,
we're doing good and I try to treat the channel at the same way I treat the
conversations that I'm having with you guys.
And I think one of the things that's really happening here is that out of this
whole crew of people,
it's like we genuinely respect you.
I want to hear from you the fact that we go out there now and it's so awesome.
There's been a couple of nights where Jordan,
I have just walked out into the audience there.
They'll sometimes there's a line around the block.
I mean literally around four square blocks in Seattle's wrapped around.
It was awesome.
And we just go out there and say hi to people.
When I've been wandering around the cities during the day,
people come up to me and they want to take me out to dinner and drink and I
joined some people sometime one night.
Uh,
where the hell was it?
Portland.
I was,
I was pretty beat after the show because it had been a long run and I went back
to my hotel and I was just going to have a glass of wine at the bar and it
turned out that like 40 people from the show were there.
We hung out and did,
did our thing there.
So it's just,
it's just been wonderful and inspiring.
And for me,
look,
you guys know I rail against the mainstream media all the time and it's like,
wow,
this thing being part of this thing has just,
it's been the proof in the pudding,
you know what I mean?
Like they say the proof is in the pudding.
Well,
all the things that I'm always talking about,
how these people are lying and not telling you what's really going on and really
going to these places and telling you the truth about what's happening.
And it's like,
I'm there,
I know what's happening.
And then I read these articles and I'm like,
you guys are all crap.
You're all crappola on a stick.
So anyway,
um,
well I'm all over the place here so we'll back up for a moment.
So we threw up that,
uh,
that classical liberal video,
two and a half minutes.
I think it got a great reaction.
Um,
tons of views,
people,
people were really happy with it.
Um,
and I think we're in try to do one of those a month.
which by the way,
those of you who support us either on Patrion on her pay power or super chatter,
whenever you're doing a,
those will,
uh,
what you're supporting us with will help us fund those cause they're not cheap
to make.
Um,
but I'm,
I'm super psyched to do more of those,
I think is a good way to get quick bites of information to people.
And it's like you can't give everybody everything in two and a half minutes,
but what you can do is open the door.
So my hope with that video was somebody would watch that.
That maybe was kind of like seeing what's happening on the left and not really
sure.
It doesn't have to put it into language to really get out what they're thinking.
My hope is that you'll watch that and go,
all right,
there's something there.
And then guess what?
You could do a little research on,
on your own.
You could go buy on liberty by John Stuart Mill.
You can get it for like five bucks on Amazon and start learning about some of
these ideas and uh,
you know,
so we're going to keep doing more of them.
I think it's really cool and that's why I'm wearing the classical liberal shirt
today.
And I sent that these ideas are coming back and for,
you know,
all the people right now,
there's so many people,
you go on Twitter,
you go on all of these things and everybody,
the sky is falling.
Everything's horrible.
World War three is going to begin it.
See all these people,
the new civil war has forgotten them guys.
Things had been bad in the past.
Things may feel bad now.
There's so many good signs also.
And that's one of the things Jordan's been talking about too.
And then a book that I have right over there,
it's Steven pinker enlightenment.
Now there are so many trends about how violence is actually on the decrease.
Now how far station I think in North America is actually expanding out.
Clean water is now accessible to more people than ever before.
I mean all sorts of things.
But we always focus on the negative.
And that doesn't mean there aren't things to fix.
And boy do.
We have a political whacked out political situation right now and people that
are just really angry at each other often for no good reason.
And we have also a set now of media people who just want to keep you enraged all
the time.
And I just don't want to have anything to do with that stuff.
So I'm just going to keep doing what I think is right.
So anyways,
so here's what I want to do.
Uh,
there are a few other things that I want to tell you about.
but I do want to do a Q and a also.
So I know there were a zillion questions and Patriana already.
We'll jump in on super chat.
So if you're watching this live on youtube right now,
you throw in a couple of bucks,
your question gets bumped up and more,
I think you put in the higher,
longer,
it'll stay there so that we can see it.
And I've got an IPAD,
so they're sending me stuff.
Okay.
Oh,
bunty king sends that says on the sexy boy,
spelled boy,
I guess.
Thank you buddy king.
Um,
do you,
uh,
super chat?
Do you feel like the ringmaster of the IDW?
So I kind of feel a little bit like the connective tissue of some of this stuff.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm not an academic,
I'm not like Jordan is an academic,
right?
Uh,
Brett is an academic,
Eric is an academic,
um,
etc. Is Heather is an academic,
etc. Etc.
I don't have a phd in neuroscience like Sam Harris,
but what I think I am is someone who can communicate these ideas really well,
who is curious about this stuff,
who really probably is a little more like you and a lot of ways than I am like
these guys and I happened to be part of these conversations.
It's the stuff that I think about that I'm deeply passionate about that I care
about,
that I love being part of this thing.
Some of you guys may have seen the picture from about a week and a half ago
where a me and Rogan and,
and Eric Weinstein and Peterson and Sam Harris and Shapiro went out to dinner
and it's like someone took a picture and they posted it and it was like,
wow,
the amount of retweets,
the thousands,
tens of thousands of retweets and comments.
Then of course all the haters saying all sorts of ridiculous things,
but it's like you guys are invested in this thing.
I know it.
I can feel it when you come up to me at the airport,
like something is shifting.
And I think at some level,
and I've been saying this at some of the shows,
I think at some level we're winning right now,
which is why some of this stuff I do think is even bubbling up to where perhaps
there was some connection where Barack Obama starts talking anti identity
politics pretty great.
And I think it's directly connected to us,
but ideas kind of move up and around and people start talking about things.
Oh,
did you read the Peters in book today?
Did you hear,
uh,
Shapiro and Peterson Winestein talking on Reuben show?
Like,
you guys know how this all works,
right?
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm super excited about all that.
So,
uh,
I love being part of this thing and I feel like we're,
we're doing actually matters.
And that does of course bring out the haters,
right?
Like I've got more haters now than ever and these trolls that endlessly,
all day long.
Like I,
like I've said this before,
I like the good troubles.
Like you're going meet me do silly stuff.
There's a guy who keeps taking Peterson to me and like making it sound like
we're saying things that were not,
but doing it in like a funny way.
Of course,
I love that stuff.
You do the cartoons about me that are silly and all that.
It's all good.
It's just these endless angry people that,
and people,
you know,
people want to attack you so that you'll respond to them so that they can get
more views.
And that's a often you views or clicks and that's often what's happening with
Jordan.
And to me it's like just I don't want anything to do with you people.
I'm,
I'm doing the best I can.
I'm open to engage in anyone that will engage honestly and d and just be a
decent human being.
And I'm here for you and I'll,
I'll continue that conversation.
So,
uh,
so anyway,
that your question,
am I the,
I don't know that I'm the ringleader of it,
but I guess that,
I guess at some level,
um,
but I love being part of it and I,
and I think it's so cool what we're doing and I think it's so cool that you guys
are so ahead of the curve on it.
It's just awesome.
All right.
Let me jump over to Patrion.
Let's see,
uh,
how much longer till we can get you on a Jiu Jujitsu map.
It'll enhance your life,
sir.
Uh,
I,
you know what,
between,
uh,
all these guys that I'm around now,
Rogan and Sam and the rest of are all into the MMA stuff.
I shouldn't start doing something.
Um,
you know,
because I've been on the road,
I've actually been able to get to the gym a lot.
I'm,
I think I'm at my lowest weight and probably like 20 years right now,
and I'm feeling pretty fit.
I'm eating right.
I'm still doing this basically Paleo,
uh,
situation.
And it's not,
you know,
people say,
well,
it's on the road.
It's like tough to eat right and sleep right and all that.
I've,
I've actually found it to be the opposite because when I'm here it's like there
is so much going on with the show and the company that we've built behind it and
everything.
I was like,
there is not a second there,
there is not a second.
And when I take a second I'm losing something else.
Right?
But when I'm on the road,
it's like,
yeah,
my phone's blowing up and I know there's always something to attend to or
whatever,
but like,
I have more time to actually get to the gym or a spine,
something to eat,
that's the right thing to eat instead of just scarfing something down for the
wrong reasons.
So I'd love to get on a Jujitsu match.
I did,
um,
acupuncture last night for the first time in my life and I saw,
I tweeted out,
signed that acupuncture.
I thought this is pretty calm,
right?
Nobody's gonna get upset by this.
Then a zillion people always say it's fake science and blah,
blah,
blah.
I don't know.
I went to acupuncture and I can tell you this guy,
puck,
you know,
pins me,
blah blah blah blah,
blah.
That a half hour I lay there and I was kind of tripping.
It felt like I was like low grade tripping.
Like I had my eyes closed,
listening to some music and I was kinda seeing stars and flowers opening up and
all kinds of weird things and like a sort of tunnel situation and I did feel
great.
And I did it at about six o'clock,
6:00 PM last night,
came home,
had a late dinner,
went to bed pretty early,
maybe 11 o'clock or so and I slept til 9:00 AM.
I haven't slept.
I usually get up now at like six 30 or something.
Naturally I slept til 9:00 AM.
So I don't know what the science behind all of it is and I'd love to discuss
that with so many,
but I did.
I did kind of,
uh,
kind of enjoy it.
All right.
Let's see.
Um,
Dennis Prager in a recent Ben Shapiro interview said that belief in an afterlife
is what keeps him seeing.
Do you think everyone pragmatically lives as if there were an afterlife?
Even if they say they may not actually believe in it?
Well,
I definitely wouldn't say everyone.
I mean I,
there are,
there are absolutely people who say they don't believe in an afterlife who don't
believe in an afterlife.
So I definitely wouldn't say everyone.
I think that the idea of an afterlife that is that if you're good here that
somehow it's going to get you to some Shangrila magical cloudy place after
probably does keep people in check a little bit.
Right.
The idea that if God is watching you,
uh,
that,
that then,
because you might get somewhere after you go that you might be on your best
behavior.
I think some people believe in that.
I don't particularly believe in that.
You don't want,
I had John Casick in here,
the governor of Ohio who ran for president.
We talked to just a bit about that at the beginning where he,
cause he was talking about how his faith and his faith is one of the things that
keeps him on the path.
And he said something that I thought it was interesting because he said,
um,
that you know,
that there's a humanist philosophy of it that you can just kind of do it
yourself.
And he said that wasn't enough for him.
I thought that was actually a pretty honest statement for a politician.
He wasn't saying,
I don't think that those are good people who either don't believe in God or,
or don't pray or don't go to church or whatever it is.
He was saying that for him personally,
his faith,
I assume you meant his faith in God or Christ or whatever it is,
that that gives him personally the,
uh,
the strength to do what he sees us.
Right.
Personally,
I do the best I can to be the best person I can be.
I fail at it often and I think you probably do too.
And whether you get the strength to do that because you believe there's an
afterlife or because you believe someone's watching you or because you just,
it's within you.
Your constitution is strong enough to,
to always do the right thing or whatever.
I don't know that it matters that much.
Um,
it's one of the cool things actually right now.
I mean these conversations that,
uh,
that Jordan and Sam are happy where they're really,
they're talking about the essence of truth and religion,
God and free will and all of this.
It's interesting to me cause I think there's a secondary conversation to happen
and maybe after they've done a couple of these,
they've done four of them.
Now.
Uh,
maybe I can host a conversation where I think we get to the next step of this,
which is all right.
I know both these guys,
I think they're both very good human beings.
Uh,
I like them both a lot.
They have a very divergent view when it comes to these big existential questions
on a micro level.
I don't think it matters at all that one of them that Jordan say is a believer
or beliefs in the importance of the archetypes of religious stories and believes
that they have some other meaning,
some deep profound truth comes out of those things.
And Sam does not believe in that on a personal level.
I don't think at a micro level,
I don't think it matters because we can all exist together and enjoy each
other's company and collaborate on things and whatever.
On the question.
And Prager brought this up when I did the God in morality debate with him and
Michael Shermer on a macro level,
do you need some unifier in his,
in his case he would argue being religion,
um,
or something from the Judeo Christian tradition.
Do you need that to keep a society moving?
Do you need this belief in an unmoved mover sorta thing?
Um,
I don't know what the answer to that is.
I nobody really knows what the answer to that is.
Um,
but I think it's an interesting question and I think what's cool is the fact
that so many people are showing up to talk about this.
So I think the secondary question of all of this is,
does it matter?
Once,
once we make the arguments that we make and all of the people who are really
thinking about this stuff.
And a lot of people don't have time to think about this stuff.
A lot of people,
it's not within their nature to think about this stuff,
but all of the people who really care about what,
what truth is and why do you either need or not need the stories and the
archetypes and religion,
all those things.
Once you get past that,
does it matter if you can coexist with the guy who lives next door,
who happens to be an atheist and you happen to be a religious person?
I think that's an interesting place to start taking this next.
Um,
but you know,
we're,
we're kind of,
that's what's cool about this.
The more conversations that we have and the more open inquiry we allow,
we allow for more room for a lot of other conversations.
So I think it's actually very cool.
Okay,
here we go.
Um,
hi Dave.
I belonged to a local,
uh,
Jordan Peterson meetup,
and we discuss thinkers like you and the Weinstein's live.
Do you have some good tips for quality conversations with the other side?
The quote other side is what you had there.
Um,
look,
the best you can do is welcome these people in here,
them out and then try.
They're going to be on the defensive.
I'm often because they're not armed with facts and they do feel very
passionately about these things and the more that you give them facts,
if it affects what they're feeling,
they're,
they're going to keep backing,
keep backing up.
Um,
just try to show people your decent,
try to show them that you're,
you're extending the olive branch,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
You reaching out to them,
all of that.
If you try to do that,
I think eventually we can get some of these people,
you know,
this mob that we're always talking about,
the mob eventually will come from them.
If you are one of the people in the mob right now and you're angry at me and
you're probably right and mean things in the comment section,
you right now person I'm talking to you who hates me,
who's watching.
I always love that there's so many people who ate that spend their time watching
this.
Um,
like if you're doing that,
no,
that generally the people that I'm sort of around and the conversations I'm
having and we don't hate you.
I don't hate you.
I W I think that we're discussing the ideas that I think are,
are a good set of ideas to help society move forward.
I think there's great discussions about should there be less government or more
government.
The the questions that I just talked about,
about God and existence and truth,
we have to show these people.
I think that we're not the bad guys.
We're not the things that people are saying about us and that the reasons people
are so angry often with us and why so many people seem to hate us and these
articles come out is because they know there's an essence of truth.
There's a kernel of truth in what we're doing and they don't know how to deal
with that.
So I suspect that's what you'd be dealing with a lot.
And I think if you keep welcoming people in and keep going,
keep look around this room.
You think there's any racists here?
Look around this room.
You think there's any massage Dennis here.
Homophobes here.
It's like,
come on man.
They're there aren't.
So I know it ain't easy.
Uh,
got to see the show in Austin and it was great.
Love what you're doing Mr Ruben and I thank you.
Thank you sir.
Um,
I did.
What's been the most surprising thing you've learned while spending so much time
with Peterson?
Love the show.
Um,
I don't,
well I don't know that this is particularly surprising,
but I can tell you this is absolutely true.
He is the same exact person when those cameras are off,
then when he is,
when the cameras are on.
So usually what goes on during the shows is,
you know,
where we get to these towns,
I usually get there pretty early in the morning symbol.
Sometimes we've traveled together,
sometimes we haven't check into my hotel dude,
my thing kind of wandered around a little bit and maybe hit the gym and then uh,
usually get to the,
to the show about,
uh,
to the theater about an hour before Jordan gets there.
About the same time,
uh,
we have two separate dressing rooms.
He gets the,
you know,
the stars dressing room.
I got the uh,
the smaller one,
but it's all good.
I usually go into his dressing room for a little bit.
We chat for about 20 minutes and it's like,
we talk about the same stuff.
Like it's not like we're suddenly talking about some other weird thing or,
or behaving differently or anything.
It's like immediately it's like,
and then,
then you know,
we have to talk about Cultural Marxism and Regina,
Dah,
Dah and his hands are moving every which way and the whole thing.
And it's like,
it's real.
He's living it and it's real.
And I think you guys are living it too.
And I really mean this,
what I said before,
if you're watching these videos and you're part of this,
know that you really are part of this.
And that's why I'm so excited about what the question was before.
People are having meetups,
you know,
when we walk out of the shows.
So usually what happens at the end of the show is if you pay a higher amount of
money,
Jordan does a meet and greet with people,
any,
any stays and takes pictures.
So I usually hang around for a little bit,
I'll go out into the lobby and people would say hi and I take a lot of selfies
and all that.
But sometimes when I walk out of the theater,
sometimes they just walk out the back and just,
cause you know,
it's been a long night and I've said my Hellos,
whatever.
But every now and again I'll walk out the front and there literally will be
hundreds of people outside just talking.
They're just talking to each other cause they're looking around and going,
wow,
this isn't a white supremacist rally,
this isn't a,
you know,
in cell hang out or whatever.
And it's like,
these are just good people who are here for ideas to talk about some stuff.
So that's why it's so cool because this thing,
it's spreading.
It's spreading in the right way.
Not because we tricked you or confused you or,
or,
or tried to get something from you.
He doesn't sell anything.
We don't sell anything at these shows.
He doesn't even sell the books,
I don't think.
I think maybe one show they sold some books.
They're not even sell them books at the shows.
You know what I mean?
Like it's,
it's good.
It's,
I'm telling you it's good.
What's going on.
Um,
okay.
Let's see.
Um,
you rock and it's time for the IDW to come up with solutions or proposals.
At least the brainpower that you gather is amazing.
I agree.
I think the next step of this is starting to move to some more solutions stuff.
We can talk about this stuff.
We can identify problems,
we can,
we can complain about our side.
We can talk about the messed up political system,
all of those things.
But at some point you move into a position where you got to talk about,
uh,
you got to talk about answers,
right.
And Solutions.
And I think we're shifting there.
There had been some discussions about this with the whole crew and I think,
I think we will get there.
Um,
let's see.
This is my request to get Joe Rogan on your show.
Uh,
I've seen you on his show and I love the back and forth.
Love your show from Andre in Aberdeen,
Scotland.
Thank you.
My friend.
Uh,
we're working on getting Rogan.
It's just,
he's told me he'll do it,
you know what I mean?
He didn't Shapiro's show before me,
which is really fucked up.
Uh,
but yes,
he said he'll do it.
Uh,
I put in a request,
I emailed him about September,
I believe it's September 11 to do my second show back.
Oh,
and I want to talk about going off the grid because I am going off the grid for
August,
but I'll get back to that in a little bit.
Um,
let's see,
um,
from,
wow,
you guys wrote a lot of,
a lot of long winded stuff here.
Let's see.
MMM.
Ah,
this is interesting.
Members of the Ibw seem divided between having a spirit of optimism or pessimism
regarding the future.
Since it may be tough to narrow it down to one,
what are the three indicators that would help sway someone towards an optimistic
outlook of the future of American politics and culture?
When IDW members say they are pessimistic about the future,
what does that mean and what does it,
what is the educated forecast about what lies in the future?
Uh,
and any chance of you and Peters and doing some shows in Australia.
We've talked about that.
So we are extending the tour.
The tour was originally supposed to be just two months,
May and June.
Then they extended July.
I'm doing about six shows with Jordan next week.
And uh,
all in Canada.
Uh,
then Jordan's continuing for a few dates in August.
I'm going off the grid and August,
which as I said,
I'll tell you a little bit more about momentarily,
but then we did extend it into September and October and a and no worry,
you're going to get shows from the Ruben report the whole time.
Even sometimes I'm coming home and taping three shows and then leaving on a
plane that night.
Uh,
but we're going to keep pumping out content here and,
and being as attentive to everything we're doing here is before.
I just think being part of something that is so powerful and culturally
important and relevant is,
is something that I want to continue being part of.
Um,
so to your question about this divide between the optimists and the pessimists,
so without,
without naming names specifically,
so I would say,
and I've said this before,
I would say I'm a world weary optimist.
I'm an optimist in that I truly believe that most people are basically good.
I think you want to do good.
I think people want to be good to the people around them.
I think they want to be good in their community.
I think people want to take care of themselves and their property and not kill
and murder and maim and steal and cheat.
Now have we all done some of those things?
Do we all get off the path and we all get confused and angry and act out in ways
that are not good?
Yes,
absolutely.
But I,
I truly believe that the human spirit,
whatever you want to call that,
does want to be good.
I think you want to do something,
you person watching this right now,
you want to do something fulfilling in your life that you feel good about,
that doesn't feel meaningless to you,
that you feel has some worth for you and hopefully your,
your friends and your family and your boyfriend or girlfriend or whatever it is.
So to that end,
I'm an optimist because I believe in that.
I believe that is within all of us right now.
I would say the world weary part of that is because it gets,
it gets kind of fucked up along the way,
right?
There's a lot of bad actors out there.
You could have,
you could have 80% good people.
Basically people trying to do good,
but you've got 20% of loud influential bad actors.
They can affect a lot of good people and confused a lot of people and I think
that that's what's partly happened here,
the media and this game of identity politics has tried to turn us against each
other in the worst ways.
It really has.
I mean,
think about it.
Let me just,
if you really want it to,
I dissect identity politics at the worst level where we were.
Some people should have something based on the color of their skin and get a job
for this,
and if you say,
okay,
look,
if you say someone based on the color of their skin,
should have more access to this education or this job or whatever it is,
or their sexuality or whatever their oppression might be,
or perceived depression,
it's not,
that all sounds good,
right?
I want to help somebody who's been marginalized.
Okay,
that sounds good on its head.
I want to help somebody else.
But what you're also saying is,
I'm going to help this resentment.
You have to take something away from somebody else who often doesn't deserve to
have something taken away from.
I think this is why for the last year or so I've been saying the next move by
the left was to come after the Asian because Asians by and large,
Chinese,
Japanese,
Korean,
whatever it is,
uh,
have put an incredible focus on education and work and family.
And because of that have moved up and up and up.
And I think,
um,
I think are pretty much at the highest echelon of socioeconomic status and all
the ways that we judge it now what's going to happen,
and we know that this is happening.
We know this is happening at Harvard and Google had this thing where they
weren't going to hire a male Asian engineers is you're going to start punishing
those people.
Most Asian people,
their grandparents or whatever it was,
came here with nothing.
Just like my grandparents,
great grandparents came over with nothing must like most likely your great
grandparents or whatever it is.
He came here with nothing.
Should we know,
start punishing people who did the right thing along the way.
Of course not.
But now what do you do if there are some groups that have been harmed more than
others by certain things?
Well,
I would say maybe you can invest more in education,
right?
Maybe we can look at what are we doing with,
uh,
with uh,
prison laws and things like that in prison reform.
Um,
but the idea,
this identity politics,
why it is so dangerous is that we'll start pitting us against each other for all
of the wrong reasons.
You can be against somebody because of their ideas and not,
and you know,
gap.
Okay.
So that person's pride,
this person's roadways.
Well,
as long as you're not killing each other,
you can be against each other for ideas.
But if we keep,
if we start putting laws in place that are going to codify the,
the dangers of identity politics,
you're going to actually have Asian people angry at black people.
You're going to have white people angry at this person.
You're going to this person angry,
this person,
not because of their ideas and their,
their truth and who they are.
But because of their immutable characteristics,
you will put prejudice into laws.
That's where this all heads.
So that's what we have to fight.
And I'm an optimist because of all the reasons that I've said for the last 45
minutes.
I think something cool is happening.
Um Oh,
but I was going to say this earlier,
you know,
when I've said we're winning,
um,
Jordan's brought up an interesting point at some of the shoulders cause I'll,
I'll say to the crowd,
you know,
something like,
I feel like we're winning.
It's so cool.
And everybody starts applauding and going crazy and they look around,
they see other people and yeah,
it's awesome.
But what Jordan's point has been is that it's not you,
it's not that you want to with,
because if you win,
that means the person who you're with is the loser.
And we don't want half the country to feel like losers because they will get
really angry and upset and everything else.
So what you want to do is you want to wake up as many people as possible to good
ideas.
And I think that that's where the focus has to be as for those that are,
those are the crew that maybe your pessimists,
there's are a lot of reasons to be pessimists and maybe that is just something
fundamentally built in to who we are.
Um,
but for now and you know,
only 42,
I still got a little optimism in me.
Um,
okay.
super chat.
Um,
I'm an atheist conservative and just you as a person made me feel super
accepted.
Oh,
that's awesome.
That's great to hear.
Yes,
there are atheist conservatives.
It's incredible.
There's all sorts of people out there and it's not just what the media tells
you.
Let's see.
I've been bugging Heather on Twitter to make Brett make more content.
They're both great in their ideas,
always make me question in mind.
They're both spectacular.
You have not seen my interview with other hiring,
which we posted I think two weeks ago.
It's phenomenal.
What a,
what a tour de force of intellectual will have.
She is,
I just loved every moment of it.
We'll definitely do more with her.
Um,
I should tell you by the way,
that,
uh,
you know,
as these tours are going on and,
and Sam's doing the stuff with Peterson and Peterson and I are continuing this
thing.
We are working on all sorts of things in the future,
uh,
that I can't quite get into now that we'll have a technological component that
could happen,
um,
uh,
touring component and all sorts of stuff.
So,
so stay tuned.
I think there's so many cool things happening and a,
and you guys are all part of it.
My friends.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'll jump back into a patriarch for a moment.
Um,
did keep up the good work on the Diet and exercise plan.
Do you look 10 years younger than you did six months ago?
You know,
I feel like I look younger.
Um,
and I definitely feel better.
I'll mention something that I mentioned on the Rogan podcasts.
So,
um,
about three,
about three years ago,
right when the,
uh,
the Rubin report was first taking off.
So this is when we were on aura TV.
This is the,
I believe this started,
it was around February or March of 2016 so we relaunched the show in September
of 2015 at aura TV,
Larry King's digital network.
And that was my first real interview was the first time I met Sam Harris and had
him on,
I think that was September 9th,
2015 and then the show really started blowing up.
I had,
I had my jacket on and I had Douglas Murray and I under see Ali and a whole
bunch of people.
I started really talking about what I thought was wrong with the left.
I started really focusing on free speech.
The show was growing and growing and growing and growing.
I started getting a lot of hate at the same time and I had never really gotten
hate before.
And I guess I was more stressed than I thought I was because around February or
March,
um,
I started losing just chunks and chunks of hair,
mostly from the back of my head.
But I lost a lot up here.
I mean,
I'm talking like I would take a shower just like it was awful,
like handfuls of hair falling out.
Uh,
I went to a,
to a dermatologist and went to do a specialist,
uh,
turn it.
Turns out I developed something called Alopecia Areata,
which is an auto immune disease.
They don't know exactly what causes it.
I didn't have any blood problems or anything like that.
Uh,
but basically your white blood cells start attacking your hair follicles.
and they don't know why.
So I ended up going on this.
I told this story to Rogan a couple of weeks ago.
Um,
I ended up going on a pretty experimental,
uh,
drug,
which I can't even remember what it's called right now.
It's got a crazy long name.
Um,
that basically was like putting like this cream that was like,
um,
it was like putting a poison ivy on my head and I had to put it on at night,
David and put it on my head.
And in effect,
what that would do is it would cause an allergic reaction so that the white
blood cells would attack the reactions that have the hair follicles.
Well anyway,
this is a pretty experimental thing.
And as I did it and I had to do it for a couple of months,
I was breaking out like you wouldn't believe.
Like my entire body was itching,
like almost everything except my face,
which was a freaking miracle,
was itchy and red and kind of flaky.
I couldn't really be out in the sun.
I'm talking about for almost a year.
And it was,
it was miserable.
I mean my,
my head,
like I was having an imagine putting,
reimagining,
rubbing poison ivy on your head,
like itching and oozing.
I mean it's really gross,
Steven.
Talk about it was,
it was pretty miserable and a,
and I didn't tell anybody about it.
I mean,
David knew and my,
my mom or my folks knew maybe my brother and sister,
like a couple of people,
but I didn't,
I didn't want to,
you guys know.
But anyway,
this,
this medication,
it also caused,
um,
I was kinda like inflamed a little bit and I definitely was like a little more
bloated and I,
I definitely,
I did not look great.
I wasn't sleeping that well.
Um,
and if anything it added more.
Uh,
if I was trying to get rid of stress,
it added more stress and it really sucked because it was happening at the same
exact point as I was becoming really successful.
Which is some sort of an interesting thing that life deals you with things.
And it's interesting because I've talked about this privately with Jordan and I
hope he doesn't mind me if I,
if I quickly mentioned this year,
but you know,
in the last two years as Jordan and succeeded,
he started having some,
uh,
some real digestive issues.
You know,
he's doing it.
He's doing a very strict,
um,
carnivore diet right now,
which,
um,
you know,
he doesn't really like talking about because he's not a Dietitian.
He's not telling anyone to do what he's doing.
But we both dealt with sort of health issues as,
as we were succeeding,
which is a really weird thing,
like as all the things that you care about that are good or are working that you
suddenly have something that's completely out of your control happening to you.
So anyway,
it really,
really sucked and uh,
yeah,
I I I definitely did not look great and uh,
it's not fun having like a thing that you don't want to talk about with people
and all that stuff.
Um,
it's,
it's mostly gone but actually today I just went to the,
to the dermatologist.
I still do,
this is all my hair,
so my hair it here.
Um,
but I still do have a couple spots in the back,
which is my,
my hair is a little bit longer in the back and a once a month I get cortisone
shots,
which I think we're going to actually stop doing.
I discuss with my dermatologist today cause they,
it's hard to tell if it's actually working,
but some are growing back and sometimes randomly there'll be like a little spot
that just appears.
They describe it as like an ember in a fire just magically appears.
But anyway,
it's just a,
it's just one of those things.
And uh,
you never know what somebody actually dealing with.
I guess just try to be decent to people.
Uh,
I have VIP tickets for a show in Cincinnati.
How can I interact with you and JP without making a fool of myself?
I'd have to know more about you specifically to know.
Um,
but,
uh,
Cincinnati,
I'll make sure that I come out in the audience for a little bit and then try to
grab me and say hi.
I'd love to say I,
um,
let's see.
Um,
when the right is the only side that is tolerant for differing opinions,
lifestyles and perspectives,
how do I employ to bracing them,
not out of alignment with all of their principals,
but out of disgust and rejection from the new extreme left?
I love this question.
I'm a classical liberal,
but it's hard when I feel like I'm so alone in the mainstream narrative when
talking to people who don't follow things like the IDW or a Peterson or who are
so brainwashed by progressivism.
Okay,
I know a lot about this cause I'm kind of in the boat with you,
right?
Like the people that five years ago I thought were the bad guys,
the evil conservatives and Shapiro and tighter and by these scary people,
once you get to know them,
you realize they're not that bad.
And just because somebody believes in limited government and low taxes doesn't
mean they ate a poor people.
And just because somebody is is,
uh,
prolife,
which I am not,
doesn't mean that they hate women or all of the memes that unfortunately the
left has put out there to make it seem like anyone who doesn't believe in their
orthodoxy is an evil person or a Nazi or a white supremacist or anything.
And I know that literally millions,
if you are waking up to this,
I have absolutely no doubt about it.
So how do you deal with it?
Well,
look,
I can tell you this,
I,
I now am friends with all sorts of,
of conservatives and people on the right and I go to these turning point USA
things.
I'll be in DC next week.
I'm doing the turning point USA highschool summit.
It's the largest gathering of high school conservatives,
I think in the,
in the country.
Um,
I'll be speaking,
I think Trump junior is going to be there and Seb Gorka is going to be there at
candidates.
Owens will be there and blah,
blah,
blah.
I have big political differences with these people.
And I go to these turning points things.
And Charlie Kirk said to me,
I sent it to him and he sat in this thing right here.
He said to me privately,
the first day I met him within two minutes,
he said,
Dave,
I have a lot of big disagreements with you,
but I'd love for you to start coming to some turning point events.
And I can tell you this,
I go to these events.
I talk about being gay,
married,
approached choice and against the death penalty and for reforming prison systems
and being against the war on drugs and a whole slew of other things that these
guys aren't really for.
And I find them to be incredibly engaging and open and nice and decent and fun.
So yes.
Are there some things that I don't like about them?
Sure.
Are they a little too conservative for my style?
Yes.
Um,
but is there room to build some alliances over there?
They're damn well is and I'm going to keep doing it.
And it sounds like you're going to keep doing it too.
And I think the more that you do that and the more that we show people that we
can,
we can be friends with people we disagree with and we can show people that we
don't have to be endlessly hysterical or outrage or angry.
They're going to run out of steam.
And I think we're starting to see some of that right now.
They really are going to run out of steam and let's just build a home where
enough people can come into town to find some answers.
Um,
super chat.
Do you get concerned about overexposure with folks like you,
Shapiro Peterson and others all over youtube and click click bait videos out
there causing discord?
Are you concerned?
And if yes,
do you have any strategies for addressing it?
So I think there is some element of that,
right?
Like a lot of us are out there doing a lot of different things.
We're doing each other's shows,
we're doing many other people's shows,
we're doing live events,
we do a podcast and all that.
Um,
I'm somewhat aware of it and I've actually in the last two months or so,
and it partly is because of the tour and I just had a time,
I've turned down a lot of media requests.
Um,
I will be on Tucker Carlson tomorrow night actually.
and people said,
why do you only go on and talk where you're and Gutfeld you only go on Fox News,
CNN and MSNBC.
I've never invited me.
I can't just stand up there and go guys,
but you'll let me.
Um,
so I'll go where I'm,
I'll go where I can go and be on live and unedited.
Greg's show is live to tape so they air the next day.
But I know Greg well and he's friend and they've never edited a word and he's
promised me that they never would.
And Tucker is aired lot so I have no problem doing that.
I much prefer to do it in studio and when I'm in DC then I been doing the camera
thing cause it's a little weird.
You sit in the little room and you stare at a little box and uh,
that's it.
You can't see him.
You're just looking at that thing and talk to that.
So it's a little weird.
But that's what I'll be doing tomorrow cause I'm here in la and he said he'd
see.
Um,
but as far as over exposure,
I would say we all have to be somewhat aware of it,
but you know,
it's a little bit,
you know,
it's kind of like,
like I don't see the term regressive left anymore.
Like really a,
when's the last time you've heard me say I very,
very rarely say it and if I do it,
I usually say it in a joking matter for all that year that I had to say it all
the time.
It was because we were trying to identify a problem and sometimes you need a
word to identify it and the idea that they were not progressive for real
progress,
which would be for quality,
but they were regressive.
They wanted us to look backwards.
They wanted us to not do the things that Martin Luther King Jr wanted us to do
it.
It was a word that really stuck,
which by the way,
just for the record,
one more time I'd utilize came up with the word.
I just was one of the people that helped amplify it.
Okay.
Now
I don't use it anymore because I think sometimes once you've identified
something enough,
you don't have to keep going back to it.
Other people can use it,
whatever.
You can figure out other ways to talk about things.
I think there there is some risk of,
because there's a bunch of us now and we're all kind of um,
picking up steam in different ways,
there's some risk of some level of overexposure.
I don't think we've hit it yet.
What I would say is if you're asking me this question,
and I guess for those of you that are watching this right now,
most of you,
obviously new people are coming on board all the time,
but a lot of you,
the core group of you that watch all of these videos and they care about this
stuff and then come up to us on the streets and all that.
You've been around for awhile.
So some of this may seem occasionally repetitive to you or oh,
I've heard that before,
whatever.
But really what you have to think about,
and I'm keenly aware of this because sometimes I will have to repeat myself when
I say something or if I give a speech,
I usually try to have no notes in front of me.
But every now and again there's a couple of lines that I know I've said before
that I really want to hit home.
You got to remember that there's so many new people coming to these ideas and
these ideas still are ignored by mainstream and the more they ignore them,
the more people tune them out and they tune us in.
So because of the amount of new people that are coming in,
we do have to be somewhat aware of not becoming characatures of ourselves by
overly repeating things.
I have discussed this privately repeaters and a little bit.
I think we all have to be aware of it.
Um,
and you guys,
those of you that are,
that are good,
decent people.
I mean if you see it,
if it seems like,
you know,
we were just,
oh,
that he's going to his old hits instead of thinking of new stuff and figuring
out what's next,
please call us out.
And by the way,
that's why the question earlier was so good about,
well,
all right,
well how do we start talking about solutions?
Because I don't always want to just talk about the ideas.
I also want to figure out what's next,
which also is why when I had,
uh,
Ben and Jordan and Eric in here a two,
two or three weeks ago,
uh,
I said,
do you guys think this is the beginnings of a political movement?
That they all had sort of different answers on that,
but look,
if it starts becoming a political move,
are some of us suddenly political consultants or political candidates or
spokespeople?
Who the hell knows?
But let's,
let's keep going.
Let's keep going and see what happens.
All right.
Uh,
uh,
man,
there's a lot of good stuff here.
Um,
so a couple of you have asked me about can you look into comic skate and
interview Ethan Van Scriber?
What's going on in the comic book community is crazy.
So I've gotten a couple emails about this.
I've heard about this a little bit.
Let me do a little bit more research.
I'll see what I can do.
I see there's a bunch of super chat questions about that.
Um,
oh,
and he's the illustrator from,
from 12 rules for life.
Right?
All right.
Okay.
Give me a little time on this one to pull this one altogether.
Let me jump back into Patriot.
Um,
couple of people asking about Obama and the comments.
I addressed that earlier.
Yes,
I do think it could possibly bring some sanity left,
but I don't know.
Um,
hey,
day personal question.
Are you a novel reader and if so,
what are some of your favorite novels?
So I haven't really been reading novels lately because I've been reading more
books of the,
of the people that come in here.
Um,
I am reading a CS Elliot short story right now or it's not a short story,
it's it,
but it's a thin book.
Oh Man.
I can't remember what it's called.
I've heard about half of it already.
Uh,
it's in my travel bag if someone wants to see if they can find it,
but I'm really enjoying that.
Um,
it's about these,
these two guys that basically kidnap another guy and bring him to,
to uh,
another planet.
Somebody helped me with this.
What the hell is it called?
Um,
okay.
you should get this person in a lot of,
um,
Dave,
you need to get Joel Kotkin on the show.
I've seen a couple of out him,
I think his criticism about texts embracive progressiveness of progressive
causes are right in line with the intellectual dark web.
I'll look into that.
But look,
even the,
even the tech companies are starting to get it.
I'm hearing I,
again,
I can't tell you every conversation I have,
but I'm hearing from big tech CEOs these days.
I mean not every,
everyone,
not everyone isn't progressive and a lot of them feel hostages at their own
companies because of the way this craziness has spread.
And I think they are starting to wake up.
I don't think it's a coincidence.
In fact,
I know it's not a coincidence that Peter Teal is moving down to la and getting
out of silicon.
The what progressivism does in its current incarnation,
it stifles thought.
It stifles thought and it demands obedience.
And I know if you're like me,
you don't want to bow and you,
and you certainly don't want to bow forever.
And that's what they demand at.
If you,
and it's,
and it's sucky and it's shitty and don't do it.
Okay.
Let's see.
Um,
I heard you on Joe Rogan talking about Nexgen after millennials.
He said that the next generation will be different because of the shit they see
now.
Do you agree?
So there's a couple of interesting things happening here,
right?
So I'm,
I'm generation x,
right?
So I'm after the baby boomers then there was generation x generation y,
so I'm 42 generation y is people I think that are basically sort of in their
late twenties to mid thirties,
I think.
I think 35 is the cutoff to generation x,
but you know,
these things are little amorphous.
Um,
and then there was the millennial generation and the millennial generation is
sort of the generation that ushered in the outrage and upset,
you know,
it was obsession with technology and all the stuff.
I don't blame them for any of it because they were brought up on all of this
stuff and you know,
feelings over facts and the rest of it.
Then there's been a bunch of studies that the generation beneath them,
the generation that's like in junior high and I think,
I think probably at the high school now,
but they're actually growing up,
much more conservative that they realize that this endless screaming and hating
each other and identity politics,
that they're against all of these things and there's been a comeback to some
sort of a conservative values.
However you want to define that.
I think that's really interesting and I think we're going to keep seeing the
fruits of that,
but more than anything else,
I mean I think the through line of this conversation that we're having today is
that let's give people a better option for the future.
Like right.
Even right now,
let's say you're a huge mega person.
You're a huge Trump person right now.
Well,
I think everyone realizes whatever side you're on right now,
I think everyone realizes this,
this level of tension and us against them,
whatever side you're on,
it can't last forever.
What could happen is it could snap and something really awful could happen,
right?
But I think what actually could happen is out of the chaos that seemingly is
happening now is that eventually the chaos won't be needed anymore.
The disruption that Trump was to the system eventually won't be needed.
And then perhaps some principled conservatives,
so principled libertarians,
some principals,
liberals,
and perhaps even,
I'll put it out there.
So some principled,
progressive who I may disagree with,
but our principled
can actually start coming out of the woodwork again.
I've talked about in several times here.
I think it's starting to happen.
I think there's some signs of it.
It's pretty cool.
All right.
Here's where,
no,
we're going to go for about 10 more minutes.
So if you got any,
uh,
any other super chats or questions on,
on Patriot and let me know what else did I want to just tell you real quick.
Oh,
um,
let's see.
Um,
so one of the thing that I wanted to hit on before,
uh,
before I wrap up and then I'll,
I'll hit a couple other questions is,
so I am going off the grid in August.
So I did this last year.
I literally locked my phone and a say from August 1st until the last day of
August.
Um,
and then my first show back last year,
which was with,
uh,
was we build a Franco.
My intention actually for my first show back in September,
right after Labor Day was to not know anything.
I was just going to come back,
sit with Phil.
And Phil obviously talks about the news often and I think he's,
I think he's a great guy and I think he's doing great stuff.
My intention was to not know anything the night before I came back at the last
minute,
I was invited to a pretty power player dinner.
We're all sorts of current events I knew were going to be discussed.
So I met Eric Weinstein first for a glass of wine and he just unloaded on me on
what had happened over the course of a month.
And there was all this North Korea stuff and the Charlottesville thing and a
zillion other things that I had no idea about.
He just like downloaded them all into my brain and then we'd go off to this
side,
big influential dinner.
It was,
it was pretty nutty.
But,
um,
this,
this year I am,
I'm going to go off the entire time,
uh,
at the end of July.
These last couple of days,
we're taping a ton of stuff,
so you will have shows every week.
We are not taking a week off.
Um,
by the way,
we have,
uh,
Josephine Matthias on tomorrow.
Who many of you guys know from Youtube?
Uh,
my name is Josephine.
She's just just absolutely wonderful and I've got to know her in person,
a little bit Sar in Toronto and she's just lovely and really smart,
cool,
fun thinker.
Um,
but anyway,
we'll put up shows in all this.
And I'm going to challenge some of you,
I don't know exactly how we're going to do this.
So when I do the off the grid thing,
I literally phone in a safe.
I'm not going to watch TV.
I'm not going to do anything electronic.
I'm going to work on my book again.
I'm going to skip.
I'm going away for a little bit of an escape and try to relax and just enjoy
myself and whatever else and sees family and friends.
Um,
I know that a lot of people can't,
can't do that,
like that level of off the greenness or disappear.
Uh,
but I am going to figure out a way,
maybe we'll do a video about it the day before I go to challenge.
Some of you guys,
you know,
I've been trying to do it on the weekends.
I don't try.
I really,
really try not to look at my phone or at least use social media on the weekends.
I think people do need an escape.
I think if there's ever a month to do it,
I think August is the month to do it.
I would love to challenge some of you to really do it with me.
If you could really,
what if you really didn't even just social media.
I know it would be hard for some of you that through because of work you
wouldn't not be able to email let's say.
Um,
but even if you just got off social media for a month,
like what would it be like,
and I can tell you that there's a level of withdrawal.
Like the first couple of days my hand kept going into my pocket,
where's my phone?
And then by day four or five it starts kind of feeling good and then that by by
day eight,
it's kind of empowering.
You're like,
holy cow,
I don't need any of that.
And then you,
you,
your,
your attention span your turns and you start,
uh,
interacting with strangers more.
One of the things I noticed,
I know this is sounding,
this sounds like such a little nonsensical thing,
but I've really noticed,
um,
I was at the supermarket after about 20 days of being off the grid and I
remember putting my stuff on the belt and the girl,
the cashier is there and I just started being friendlier to how you doing?
What's going on?
Oh,
I saw you here last week about,
oh,
this thing that I bought,
like this was,
this was pretty good.
So I bought it again,
whatever.
And it was like you can make room in your brain again to be the way we were 20
years ago.
Like of course technology is great.
You're watching this on youtube right now.
We can connect in all these different ways,
right?
I meet some of you guys in real life because of this.
Um,
but just remember 20 years ago we had none of this stuff and we had none of this
stuff in the thousands of years of humanity before that.
Um,
so I'm looking forward to the escape.
I will challenge some of you to join me for the month and just see what happens.
But even if you can only get off,
uh,
get off so to speak,
for the weekend or whatever it is,
I think it would be pretty cool.
So hopefully some of you guys will join me for that.
Oh,
and then,
uh,
I will tell you this,
our first show back is on September 4th.
It's the day after Labor Day.
I am not going to know anything and I will be a guest on the Rubin report.
We have a guest host on the Ruben report who is going to,
uh,
give.
He's going to interview her.
I just said it's a he.
Okay.
So he's going to interview me and fill me in on all the things that I missed and
you guys,
we'll,
uh,
we'll watch that live as I get the full download live.
Uh,
we're going to do that on September 4th,
but I'm not saying who it is.
Um,
you know,
I think maybe a moment ago that I said that Josephine is a conservative.
I don't know that actually she's,
I don't think she fully,
I think she's a classical liberal.
Um,
I think she's got some conservative views.
And the reason I said that was because she did a video that I think it was
titled Black People can be conservative.
Um,
I don't think she herself identifies as a conservative.
So just mean if you're watching,
I apologize for miss labeling.
You,
there's nothing worse.
Oh,
the book that I love.
Silent Planet,
a CS Lewis.
So it's a trilogy I'm in.
I'm still on the first one,
but I'm going to knock it out and hopefully on my next travel.
And,
uh,
all right,
let's see.
Super Chat.
The interesting thing about watching so many of you for so long is that it helps
cement the ideas,
but we also get to see the evolution of the ideas and arguments.
Love your work,
especially with Jordan.
Thank you very much.
Um,
there's a bunch of you that wrote a lot of Nice things about me.
Thank you.
I love what you do,
man.
Took me,
uh,
from ignoring all the noise to finding some hope for honest discussion,
important port conversations.
Thank you.
Uh,
I DWI dia have been specific shows.
For example,
having bread and Dawkins on would be great to have multiples perspective from
specialists.
Yeah.
So we're thinking about all of this stuff and I think partly once we figure out
how we can talk more,
you know,
it's not easy to put these things together and manage.
We got people that live in all sorts of parts of the parts of the country.
And you know,
Douglas Murray for example,
in Majid both,
uh,
live in the UK.
So,
uh,
we're,
we're figuring it all out.
We're,
we got a lot of cool stuff planned.
I'm super psyched about everything that's going on.
Oh.
And by the way,
the show is expanding.
We are,
we are building out our team.
Uh,
just yesterday actually we hired a new team member who I will introduce to you
at some point along the road.
Um,
but yeah,
we you guys that,
that support us whether it's on Patriot or paypal or super chat,
you're helping us build out this thing and uh,
and I hope you're proud of it and I hope you're excited and as excited at least
as I am.
And uh,
all right,
so I think we're going to wrap this thing for now.
I just wanted to catch up on a whole bunch of stuff for Ya.
I think we'll probably do a livestream if possible on July 31st so that it can
be my official goodbye and my official challenge for you guys to join me off the
grid if you can.
And then as I said,
we got,
we got new content coming out all of August.
We've got some really cool stuff planned for,
uh,
for September they were,
there was a huge guest that I thought we were going to have in May that it got
delayed a little bit.
I think that's happening in September.
And uh,
just keep fighting the fight guys.
Like just keep,
keep fighting,
keep giving people a chance to,
to,
to learn with you,
uh,
to not judge them as quickly as they would judge you.
And let's see what we can keep building here because uh,
it,
it's happening.
It's happening whether we like it or not,
I happen to like it,
but it's happening whether we like it or not.
So thank you guys.
Oh,
and by the way,
if you want to get your classical liberal t shirt,
I believe the link is right down below.
You can go to the Rubin report.com/store.
There's some other Rubin report stuff on there and all that good stuff.
All right,
I am going to dinner.
Thanks guys.
See Ya.
Oh,
and we'll get the fricking tri caster work in next time,
so you don't have to stare at me looking at my computer.
Okay.
Bye.